(whew)
Ha ha.
Whoo-whee!
Miss Clarissa,
I'm gonna tell you, girl.
In that dress,
you looking about as sweet
as a field full of honeysuckle
after a spring rain shower.
[chuckles]
How do you do it, girl?
Mm!
That ass, though.
- What was that?
- What was what?
What you just said to her.
Oh. Well, I was
just following your lead.
No you wasn't.
You was being all heavy-handed
with it, man.
You got to be subtle.
- Subtle.
- Exactly.
You got to be subtle if you
wanna talk to them ladies.
I can do that.
[bluesy harmonica]
Whoo hoo hoo!
Whee!
Miss Denise, girl,
the way that dress
is flowing,
you look like a mountain creek
after a spring thaw.
Simply refreshing.
What...is...your...secret?
The way that dress
fitting on you
got them...titties
popping out.
- What--
- Amazing.
What. Is. Your.
Secret?
What are you--
what are you doing?
I was just doing
what you was doing.
No, you wasn't.
I even said
"What. Is. Your. Secret?"
- That's verbatim!
- That part was.
Did you hear me say anything
about anybody's titties?
No.
You know what?
How about we just say
no words altogether.
- No words altogether.
- Mm-hmm.
- Question.
- Yes?
- How will I talk?
- You're not gonna talk, okay?
All right.
Hoo hoo whee!
Ladies, I'm sorry,
y'all hurt my eye.
Y'all just, like, smoldering.
Like the sun.
And just as bright in them
beautiful dresses.
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm!
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-
mm-mm--
Mm! Mm! Mm!
Vagina.
What the hell was that?
Oh. I did say a word
at the end there, didn't I?
Did you see the part
where all this was going on
and shaking your tail feathers
and whatnot?
I didn't see it--I got
the worst view in the house.
That's what
chased them away, man.
- All right.
- You know what?
- Stay away from me.
- All right.
Whoo whee!
Miss Laverne.
You like
a long-stemmed rose,
the way
you looking and smelling.
Mm-mm-mm-mm!
What is your recipe?
Damn, boy.
I bet you got a big old dick
and balls.
I love you.